i just got to say it i mean this is a
lot of what we're talking about is
indicative of some kind of western or
u.s cultural or governmental collapse
absolutely that's why i think a
convention of states
we've already got people who are
chatting saying like they think it's a
bad idea for a variety of reasons which
we'll definitely get into in a bit but
what i want to say is when you take a
look at what's going on with china what
do they have they have a strong
authoritarian structure a a
a mono culture
that is the ccp the chinese communist
party people like to often point out
like we're not talking about the chinese
people we're talking about their
government and i'm like yeah yeah look i
i think i think colloquially it's
understood we're talking about their
government the stranglehold the
government hold the government has the
suppression of information they have we
don't have that in the united states to
a certain degree we do obviously big
tech censorship the corporate propaganda
press will will run lies
but this show exists so we're clearly
better than china but that's also as
much of it as it is as much as it is a
strength it's a it's something they
exploit they know there are people in
this country that they can pay who will
say whatever needs to be said because we
don't have a cohesive shared culture
anymore it used to be we were talking
about this last week with the fall of
empires i think zubi was bringing this
up
that when you no longer have the idea of
like god in country i don't mean that
literally gotten country i mean like
this idea of like this is our country
this is what we believe this is what we
share that's our experience
when you don't have that anymore your
country can be gutted ripped apart and
that precipitates the collapse so now i
see what's happening with china they're
absolutely exploiting our political
divisions how much longer can we last
when you have the thousand talents
program china goes in and they pay
professors to to give up our research
where you've got stories about chinese
nationals ferrying
viruses and vials getting caught and
arrested
there's there's no respect for this
country and the problem is
we don't have a unified culture of a
culture war which means they can keep
just chipping away at the crack until
the rock splits well that's the intent
the culture war is at least partially
being fostered by the chinese it's part
of the reason they censor our culture i
have a young friend who's on the uc
berkeley campus and one of the most
liberal campuses in the country
she's half ethnic chinese her mom was
ethnic chinese she was raised in her
family to hate america she was raised to
believe that this is a vile terrible
place that americans are not to be
trusted and that eventually china would
prevail and china specifically meaning
the ccp
that's on a mainstream college campus
that culture that idea is supported she
said the majority of the chinese that
she knew on campus believed this you
know she's welcome to walk in those
communities because of her partial
ethnic chinese background and she said
it's just horrendous it's totally
anti-american and it is at the forefront
of culture on our college campuses all
across the country
how long how how long can something like
this go on for especially you know when
i look at pelosi going to taiwan my
question is you know for what purpose
does it serve like you were saying just
a moment ago that's a lot of what people
are asking
is it a distraction is it the democrats
are failing so miserably that she's like
well this will shake up the news cycle
and get us get us off the recession
maybe the idea is like wartime
presidents do well maybe if i go there
and confront china on something it'll be
good for the democratic party
yeah to me it seems like a distraction i
mean it's a it's an excellent political
distraction they've got no good news
that the democratic party can run on
right the economy is a shamble our
industries are falling apart our
standing in the international community
is at an all-time low their own base
despises them basically at this point if
you look at the numbers among hispanics
we've never seen anything like this in
in the modern history of the country 24
approval rating for biden among
hispanics lower than among whites i mean
it's really extraordinary so she needs
to do something she needs to roll some
kind of political hand grenade in the
room to try to distract yeah i have
taken the approach throughout my time in
politics when someone does something
that i think is good for the country
even though they may be doing it for the
wrong reason i commend them for doing it
and and so i'm not going to say anything
negative about nancy pelosi going there
because i think it's it's it's the right
thing to do the fact that the fact that
my demonstration did not want her to go
and it was very clear they didn't want
her to go because they were afraid of
china's reaction and she stood up to
them and said and obviously said she was
going uh
again there may be there may be politics
behind me like everybody does everything
i have i don't know i have no id it
makes no sense to me
why she's doing it other than
she under maybe she understands
i don't i can't understand how people
don't understand how big a threat china
is and how important this conflict is
and
look we tend to think of everybody on
the other side is just
horrible terrible on everything and they
don't care about america anyway
i
look i serve with these people and and i
think
90 of the time that's true
but there are people that uh that do
care about the security of our country
and understand that china is a threat on
the other side of the aisle maybe she's
one of them again i may be giving her
more credit than she deserves but i'm
willing to give her the benefit of that
because she's doing the right thing
i i respect her going to taiwan um but i
question it obviously and it's like i
really don't like her as
as a person everything she represents
the elitism of politics i think she's a
bad person i think she's manipulative i
think she's overly emotional i think she
and and and her cohorts created until
untold problems united states during the
trump years with the obsession over
russia and the lies they espoused
and i think it's it's all that's true
right well that's true but i do you know
respect to going to taiwan i guess
but i look i know her i served with her
i spent i spent time i know nancy i mean
we're not buddies but uh and so this is
a real head scratcher for me but
yeah give her you know look thinking
about the current state of the culture
war and you know i'm thinking about
we've got the the you know the first
times of the show where like world war
three china what's happening and now
it's like uh civil war are we heading in
that direction can people trust the
politicians we've got people in the chat
who are saying you're a rhino right but
you're that's me republican
that's me um obviously nobody and and i
bet you they've been involved in
politics and have worked on conservative
causes for 40 years just like i have i
bet i'm a rhino right oh yeah i mean
this is the problem i have yeah if so
many people come up to me who have been
a conservative for 20 minutes
and and they say oh this guy's a rhino
yeah this guy's a rhino who if you if
you google my name you see what kind of
rhino i am that i've been i've been uh
ostracized for the last 20 years for
standing up for for cultural truths and
for standing up for uh a you know free
markets and look i
i i respect everybody can have their
opinion on things and one of the things
that i i realized is you just go do the
right thing and don't worry about what
other people say about you and and so
i'm i'm out here right now where i'm i'm
teaming up with another guy who's called
a rhino on occasion right
because among other things among other
things for uh for standing up for the
the ultimate in our constitutional
freedoms which is federalism the idea
that america will end up candidly in a
civil war
if we don't begin to respect that
people in some areas of the states are
going to live their lives differently
than people in other areas of the states
and by the way that was the case from
the very beginning that's what our
founders understood could hold a country
together as big and diverse even at that
point we were talking about 13 colonies
but they saw the vastness of the united
of what could be the united states and
they realized over a country of this
size you're going to have people who are
going to behave and want different
lifestyles people who are going to live
in the mountains not going to be the
same as people going to live in the
cities and and the idea that that we're
going to have a central government
that's powerful that's going to make
everybody have the same ideas and
philosophies and not give local control
and freedom to
to states and communities and families
to live their lives the way they want
they realize that that was a loser and
and so federalism was the approach and
that's what we're trying to restore
through this process rhode island rogue
island it's basically a city yeah that
has two senators that should have lost a
seat in congress during the last census
but they messed up oh wow really
wow i just think it's funny when the
democrats come out and they're like why
do why does wyoming get you know two
senators i'm like why does rhode island
it's like i understand people there
yeah right delaware and is is only a
tiny bit bigger
you know so i i got to tell you man i
don't envy you know
you being in politics people are always
mentioning like will you ever consider
politics and i'm like no never there's
no way to represent everybody and that's
exactly what the father is look i i i
think that it's a it's a ridiculous idea
that you're going to represent everybody
you got to be you have to be mentally
ill to be to be able to represent
everybody there's such diversity in this
country
i've always people have always said you
know how did you do it how did you how
did you you know go to washington and
because i always felt like my duty was
to do what gather as much information as
i could look at the context of which
everything was done and make the best
decision and then
make your case as to why you know why
why why it's right for america and not
worry about the electoral consequence
because you can't you can't just go out
and and and jump from whatever the poll
says from one time another look there's
there's there's truth i believe in it i
believe there is a truth and i believe
that that uh our founders put together a
process that in our constitution that
works and you just follow those those
two things the truth and the and and
aligning with the constitution you'll be
fine yeah
you know i look at
we we often will talk about here who's
right in the culture war the left or the
right what does left and right even mean
right i grew up liberal and here i am
being called right wing because one
simple reason i know what's going on in
the media so a really great example our
let's go i know what's going on in
politics a really good example we had a
guest on the show who claimed what i
said
joe biden said if you want the billion
dollars you got to fire the prosecutor
and he said looked at me smirked and
said it never happened
and then i pulled up the video and
played it for him and he was shocked
this is what makes you right wing these
days that if you show a video in the
news that people are talking about they
don't know why because cnn's lying
because msnbc is lying on occasion fox
news even so when you've got here's what
i see
it's the rule for the democrats that
they are misleading you it is the
exception with republicans that they're
misleading you there are a lot of bad
republicans they're often misleading you
but there's a handful of really good
ones on the democrat side i we had tulsi
gabbard i thought was being honest i
didn't agree with some of the political
positions look what happened her now
she's going on fox news now she's she's
old right now i know
because when when you talk about what's
true
that clearly makes you right wing even
if your political positions
how do we
salvage
i hate to say it this country how do we
how do we save it when you've got people
who believe
media lies that that the media can just
make something up
claim you're the one making it up and
the example i always give these are the
people who believe jesus millet these
are the people who chase after the
russia gate narrative for years and
spent tens of millions of dollars these
are the people who smeared the covenant
catholic kids
clearly they got a track record for
track record of being wrong
but there are people who just never
break out of those lies how do you how
do you do it especially when we're
talking about for for you you know or
anyone else who's in office
you're showing up and you're like okay
that's not true nancy the thing you're
saying about trump didn't happen why do
you believe that and then she votes on
something based on a fabrication they
vote because justice millet said
something
the only thing you can do is continue to
fight and tell the truth i mean that's
that's
that's all you have and i would make the
argument i mean look at this show as an
example i got involved in politics uh a
lifetime ago i was first elected to
congress in 1990 i was 32 years old and
the only way i could ever
get the truth out
was to buy an ad i i
talk radio didn't even exist
rush limbaugh was just getting started
back then you
everything was whatever the newspaper or
the television
said and there wasn't there weren't
cable news networks even back then so
all you had was the national media and
then your local media and if you had a
dissenting voice
you either had to run a campaign and buy
ads
or you had to knock on as many doors as
you could so the idea that that we are
powerless to fight against these lies
europe a case in point where that simply
isn't true the reality is we have more
opportunity to get our point across
today than we've ever had now they have
more opportunities to get there because
there's more media generally the bigger
problem we have is not that we can't get
our message out it's how do you talk to
people that don't agree with you
that's the problem the problem is you're
we're siloed everybody just gets you
know uh
information that agrees with their point
of view and they and they discount to
the point of not believing anything that
comes from people that they don't they
don't agree with it's true but it is
the the rule on the left and the
exception on the right there's a decent
amount of people on the right who
believe fake things and they just look
for tribal uh answers but on the left it
is the it's a way of life yeah so
for instance because they don't believe
in truth i mean so then i mean let's
just get to the bottom line i really
agree they they they they believe in in
a relative they have a relative
relativism point of view
it's my truth and and whatever they
think is the truth and and conservatives
by and large not all because we have
some i truth folks on our side too but
overall i think you're right it's the
exception we believe there is a truth or
is a right and wrong there is reason and
but through reason you can come to a a a
a a conclusion they don't believe that
anymore it's how i feel exactly it comes
i i always go ahead i was gonna say they
don't believe in truth they believe
there is no truth but power correct
that's it which actually the roots of it
even in our modern culture today come
from marxism i mean that is the literal
ideal of marxism and ultimately one of
the things that marxists do and they've
always done throughout history is if you
can control what people say you can
control what they think if you can
control it they think you control
reality essentially and you're in total
control then this is the ultimate aim of
totalitarianism and ultimately that is
the aim of the modern democratic party
and that's why you see a complete effort
to redefine everything to make words
mean nothing thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there